police in brazil say a fisherman has
confessed to fatally shooting an
indigenous expert and a british
journalist who went missing earlier this
month the suspect led officers to a
remote area where human remains were
found
the search for dom phillips and bruno
pereira has shed light on friction
between indigenous communities illegal
poachers fishermen and mining companies
operating in the amazon
a tragic end to an 11-day search
brazilian police say the bodies of
missing british journalists tom phillips
and brazilian indigenous expert bruno
perriera may have been found
authorities say a suspect confessed to
fatally shooting the two men
the first suspect arrested in this case
confessed to the crime
he described it in detail and pinpointed
where he had buried the bodies
clues emerged throughout the week
a spot of blood on a suspect's boat
the belongings of the missing men
but authorities drew criticism for
dragging their feet on the investigation
members of brazil's indigenous agency
funai
which periera had worked for
held a vigil for the two men
they are protesting what they see as the
government's complicity
bruno and dome were not adventurers
they were exceptional role models at the
forefront of their work
they were violently murdered by
criminals in the javari valley who the
brazilian state under the bosnaro
government did not combat
the two men had received threats for
their work in the jawari region
renowned for illegal fishing logging
mining and drug trafficking
their killings are a grim reminder to
indigenous rights workers in the region
of the dangers they face
for more let's reach out to journalist
joao pedro suarez who has covered the
story extensively he joins us from rio
de janeiro um
this is a rather a grim discovery um two
men that still have to be formally
identified if i understand correctly one
more can you tell us about the
investigation
so um
yesterday night the federal police
released the information that one of the
suspects amaliuto
oliveira he confessed having
participated
in the crime killing bruno and don
and he took the police agents to the
place where the bodies have been
butchered
burned and afterwards burned and there
the federal police found these mortal
remains of both of them bruno and dom
and now the police is still investigated
investigating a second suspect
who is being kept in custody is the
brother of amarillo
and they are still investigating the
participation the participation of a
third person and the the mortal remains
were took to brasilia today earlier so
the forensic work can be done in order
to confirm if those
those body
remains those mortar remains really
actually belong to bruno and don so they
can be delivered to the families
now i understand um actually do we know
what the motive is i understand the
investigation is still ongoing
we are still not
sure about the motive i mean the police
has not stated it officially but bruno
pereira he was a public servant in the
indigenous
institution of the brazilian government
and since the beginning of the bolsonaro
government he
he he decided not to work anymore to get
a license and he was working directly
with the indigenous invalid
so bruno was being was being threatened
for a long time and the demand amarillo
oliveira who confessed the crime he was
seen following bruno and don on the
following day on the previous day of of
the tragedy and
bruno has has conducted uh
operations against illegal mining in the
region he was a very important defendant
of the isolated indigenous peoples in
the region so bruno uh was he he was a
problem for the
the criminal groups who act in the
region and more precisely uh those uh
the amarillo oliveira is a fisherman so
there is illegal fishing in the region
related with drug trafficking so it's a
very complex context and it was there
where bruno and don were killed
very intricate indeed thank you so much
for outlining it and explaining uh
journalist joao pedro suarez uh talking
to us from rio de janeiro brazil thank
you so much phil
thank you